[Music]
all right there's an irvine
there's a company based out of irvine
that uh has agreed to pay a settlement
to the state of california wait the city
of irvine yeah well not the city but
there's a company based out of irvine
and this company for being too clean
yeah the biggest crime of all every time
this company it's a beverage company
that created a drink that they claimed
was drinkable sunscreen
what the why
why
finally
how in the [ __ ] does that even make
sense well that's kind of like tide pods
right you take it your clothes are fresh
right right wait it's drinkable
sunscreen and they they're suing the
city of california no they the uh the
state of california
is suing
is making them pay a settlement good for
false advertising good what a dumb
company i said the city of california
there's a cattle california city there's
a california city yeah oh i got to come
to you
how come it feels like uh
newsom was [ __ ] at walmart and he's
like you're telling me i could drink
this lotion
and then he drinks it
[Laughter]
because how else is the [ __ ] the state
gonna find out about this oh good
why do they drink it
why does your vehicle owner's manual
have a thing like please don't drink the
battery acid
because somebody drank the battery
you could probably drink this huh so
when i initially saw that i thought it
was like okay it's you know regular
sunscreen but if you were to eat it
nothing happens that's what i thought it
was it's actually a drink
that works as sunscreen
just you drink it and then you have
three to five hours of protection you
know what else works if you just put
sunscreen on your [ __ ] skin
yeah but it's pretty thirsty but
according to this company everyone hates
doing that oh yeah dude i do hate doing
it actually i agree i hate it because it
because if my hands are all slimy after
that i can't get on my phone and just
yeah yeah wait you could drink something
and it protects you from the sun i think
that's what the fall
advertising part is yeah their claim was
that so uh it said it provided three to
five hours
three to five hours of sun protection
from head to toe including your eyes
and that it's what's like
i'ma test it out
you remember all those chinese people
were [ __ ] staring into the sun
thinking like it's gonna help them with
[ __ ] it does though it does yeah
healing properties it does
don't don't it just [ __ ] on paper it
does it does it does it does you're
wrong
rising sun man yeah that's what they
said they said if you drink it you have
baseline protection that'll help
minimize the likelihood of burning even
if you forget to use sunscreen people
are [ __ ] nuts dude yeah so the
interesting thing about the settlement
is that
they're not accusing this company of
having of shilling like a thing that
doesn't work
that's the interesting thing is they're
agreeing to pay the settlement without
admitting that the drink doesn't work oh
this is like that one [ __ ] thing that
like finds her oh yeah like fizer yeah
yeah yeah we just pay it we just paid it
it keeps working
remember the malls the bracelets balance
beams the balance things yeah yeah the
balance bands my janitor and my old
[ __ ] work he lived and died by that
[ __ ] balance bet he's all like look
when you have this they can't i get
stronger but look oh i'm so [ __ ] weak
dude you're crazy but that was the same
thing there was like a lawsuit to be
like this [ __ ] doesn't work so instead
of saying no it doesn't work they just
like paid the settlement they just paid
the settlement instead of actually
admitting that it was a fraud yeah so
that's because they made that much money
yeah that's yeah because then you have a
yeah it's a total different lawsuit if
you're gonna if you're willing to admit
it doesn't work what flavors do they
have for the drinkable sunscreen oh it
tastes like sunscreen
no i don't know
they have copper tone flavor
bullfrog flavor
bullfrog flavor dude is bullfrog still
around for sunscreen frog sunscreen
because i remember the distinct smell of
bullfrog i like the sun bum nobody else
nobody so the the actual total of the
settlement
what do you think it is how much you
think they have to pay for 35 bucks no
it's irvine it's got to be expensive
well it's the california state they like
to tax like crazy
30 15 15. 15 mil 30 million i don't know
[ __ ] news is asking for money
probably so by the way this is this is
for deceptive advertising eight million
dollars three energies all right this is
35 bucks
it's 42
500
how the [ __ ] is the state even involved
in this thing like what the [ __ ] is
going on that's why i keep telling
[ __ ] knew some [ __ ] he's suing
personally he's i [ __ ] threw up in my
rolls royce i gotta change one of the
chairs and it was 42 grand just give me
42 grand please that actually makes the
most sense out of all these little 42
grand yeah so it's the product is made
by dr bobby awadallah he's a
dermatologist owner of the company and
he stands by it saying that it contains
30 vitamins antioxidants and ingredients
that would provide three to five hours
of sun protection if he's a
dermatologist isn't he an expert why are
we questioning him that's true he's not
a biologist oh that makes sense that's
that's the conversation today he said
one of the key ingredients is a powerful
phytonutrient get the [ __ ] out of here
including dna protection absorption of
uv light and anti-inflammation how many
times do people in like the fitness
industry like just use buzzwords like
that just to be like whoa this [ __ ] has
phytochemicals dude this is gonna
totally work i want phytoplankton
that's why
i wonder if this is kind of like a more
cost effective way of getting a product
to admit that it doesn't work kind of
like ghostedly to like the consumer this
probably happens all the time i'm just
thinking about the state of california
just like [ __ ] going down the laundry
list of all registered businesses being
like let's see where we can get money
drinkable sunscreen hello
yeah we heard there are a bunch of
complaints
i get pretty lazy like putting sunscreen
on because it is a whole process right
it's boring so now i just [ __ ] wear
um i just wear rash guards
or like i just cover up what about the
spray-on ones those those
are pretty good
ones are fun but you can't be [ __ ]
killing the reef with that one chemical
in it but also somewhere safe yeah yeah
the reef safe one because you're just
you don't have to have greasy hands or
nuts yeah oh i forgot about that do the
spray one i get lazy
the spray one yeah cause you gotta spray
and then wait and then you can't even go
in the water i do like the sun touching
my skin too to get my vitamin d's yeah i
do like that if you have the rash guard
you don't get the vitamin ds yeah you
just get these nuts you get it through
the pan and you get a sick tan though
that's your that's where sun receptors
is through the hand
i have to get to my eyes
stare at the sun
do you remember when they had uh
airborne
yeah that thing that you would take
they had the same kind of issue right
with like a unity boost yeah that it
doesn't actually do anything yeah
because they're saying it's preventative
like five of them dude in the immunity
like that [ __ ] it's just it's just like
uh electrolytes and stuff electrolytes
and vitamins yeah i [ __ ] with that
though the liquid ivs no those are fire
those are fine yeah but it's also like
you can't say it's immunity boosting it
just well is it vitamin c a [ __ ] meme
anyway like everyone's like vitamin c is
going to prevent all my names i like
oranges
cause isn't it your body can only take a
certain amount and then it just starts
purging the rest of it so if you take
like which is like a thousand five
hundred percent and those like airbornes
or whatever yeah so it's like that's why
they have it so high so your body can
absorb more of it speaking of [ __ ] iv
you guys know that there's a lot of uh
these uh little trailers that just park
up now you can walk in and then you can
do that paris hilton b12 [ __ ] where
you just get the iv
[ __ ] hook me up and make me good
again after [ __ ] clubbing all night
there you go you just kind of fire them
i got one of those when i felt like i
got coveted the first i remember we had
that jk vegas strip yeah and i got the
iv which was i have a victim but i got
[ __ ] up by the covet still no it's
very popular in south korea
the iv treatment yeah like everybody
that goes partying gets super drunk so
then they go to the hospital for us
hospitals crazy because we're like i'm
not paying a thousand dollars to jump in
the ambulance but for other places
they're like oh we take care of our
citizens just get rehydrated especially
if you're like a company man and you got
to go to the office like after the
weekend yeah so literally there's just a
bunch of people sitting there getting
their iv and then going back to work
have you guys tried it
i want to try it as a healthy man with
no parting like tendencies i just want
to sit in there and see if i feel even
better than i do for like the b12 stuff
it seems like it it checks out what
about that you guys ever done a little
oxygen bar at the airport that one i
don't feel i've done that don't feel
that that's a scam
you just got a wim hof if you want that
extra oxygen i did that [ __ ] in the
morning bro which is
have you tried it the oxygen mask
because it's at the new york new york in
the las vegas i don't know if it's like
potent enough it feels like it's just
like
because it's like what normal normal
atmosphere what's like only 30 oxygen or
something right so i'm like when you
when they have that on it's supposed to
be 100 but then it feels like it's so
like diluted that yeah there's no way
it's a hundred percent if it's 100
you're like laughing aren't you no
that's the
nitric that's nitrous oxide but even
like with a hundred percent pure oxygen
aren't you like really lifted you want
the one that's like you know the ones
when the the lifeguards they pull you
out of the ocean and then the awesome
[ __ ] is about to die and then
they put that thing on you you want that
thing that things like that
that was like 100 they used that on the
sidelines in like uh sports games oh
yeah some of them do yeah when you when
you do dance shows in colorado and
you're not like native they have those
on the side the wings of the stage
because the altitude yeah dude i tried
doing a workout in a hotel room in
colorado almost [ __ ] died man i was
like i felt that too yeah i was like
imma just do like [ __ ] club pull-ups
i thought one like this
[Music]
i think we tried to do 30 burpees we
stopped at eight and said the atmosphere
is trying to choke me
and then we just went in the jacuzzi
we went we went on a china where we went
to a place in the mountains was super
high altitude that when you got to like
the base of the mountain everybody had
to buy oxygen tanks whoa and we didn't
fully get it and stuff like that and
then when we were up there all five of
us had nose bleeds and headaches
you were being cheap yeah no we were
hitting it too but then like nobody
fully understood or grasped right like
the the severeness of the situation did
you hear on the the [ __ ] nims guy
from 14 peaks on joe rogan are you
talking about like once you pass the uh
like 7 000 or eight thousand feet
elevation mark it's called like whatever
zone where people don't [ __ ] me zone
pretty much right
but when you're at that level he says
literally when you take your glove off
to like look at your watch and put the
glove back on it feels like you're
running three miles whoa what cuz you're
tired
that's how [ __ ] slow and because
you're you're so like oxygen deprived
yeah it's a [ __ ] chore to even pull
your difference like a fat man trying to
tie his shoelaces
you're literally taking one step
like an hour you know like you're
literally going like
[ __ ] you on the moon that's hella good
slow-mo dude you shouldn't call it they
shouldn't call it the [ __ ] me zone then
because it you can't really even move
that much or you're too busy getting
[ __ ] i forgot what they called the
dead zone the something's yeah yeah i
don't should pay a fine
false advertising i want to try the
[ __ ] zone i thought the problem was
we're driving up there so we don't have
the time to acclimate and [ __ ] cause we
gotta go like that you know but then
like maybe if you walk up slowly
does that count you just stick your head
out the car we're like this hold him
yeah yeah suck a ball would you guys be
down let's say in the airplane right you
could roll down the windows for a split
second would you stick your head out to
see what it feels like [ __ ] no stick
your head away i'll stick my hand out
first i refuse to look that uncool but
you can't you can't stick your head out
oh because you could open the windows in
the small plane that i was in and they
could stick my hand out like that why
can't you stick your head of course it's
gonna fall off no it's like uh the
windows don't open did you feel like it
was like lack of oxygen up there no it's
fine maybe i wasn't high enough uh i
don't think you were in the [ __ ] zone
yet bro no probably not no way you're in
the [ __ ] zone you'll know yeah you'll
know you'll be [ __ ] why did you even
say that
you